you
one of the things that tends to
characterize the way Americans think
about progress is that we think of it as
my kind of straight line you know we
have like the x-axis and the y-axis and
you know the kind of line going
diagonally upward and that is you know
american progress as time goes here we
get better and that's actually a false
narrative that's not an accurate way of
looking at the way the country has
progressed in this country progress is
more often look like kind of like an EKG
when we have these moments and then we
have these valleys and we have these
moments and that may slope up more
upward over time but it certainly has
the kind of peak and Valley effect to it
and with Hillary Clinton's presidential
campaign we've actually seen almost kind
of overlapping things we were seeing
peaks and valleys simultaneously so it
represents a form of progress that a
American woman could be nominated for
the presidency of a major political
party and it's not coincidental that
that nomination coincides with the most
egregiously a breathtakingly vulgar
expressions of sexism and misogyny that
we've seen in American politics we quite
simply don't have a frame of reference
for this but both of those things happen
at the same time now because of an
optimist I tend to believe that the the
graph that measures kind of upward
trajectory will supersede the one at the
peaks will all eventually outweigh the
valleys but I don't think that we should
ever be nonchalant or kind of look at
history as a series of inevitable
victories for the righteous certainly
not American
history when we look at any of these
movements that have bettered life in
this country they had the potential to
fail at any moment and the ones that
succeeded that we think of as succeeding
did so precisely because of ones that
preceded it that actually did not
achieve those objectives and so if we're
talking about you know civil rights in
the 1960s well we'd have to say that the
kind of first thrust of that was in the
19th century at the end of slavery and
the kind of dawning of segregation and
those sorts of practices so it's
possible for movements that are morally
right to actually not achieve their
goals and in that regard Hillary
Clinton's nomination represents a
particular kind of progress around
gender and sex and inclusion in this
country and it also highlights the
intransigent and entrenched means at
which people want to retain the status
quo it's embarrassing to see that you
know men are still more likely to vote
for the Republican nominee whose name i
think has been said enough i try not to
say it but I think we're talking about a
kind of interest reflex about patriarchy
a very masculinist idea that people have
been waiting I think feeling like they
had to suppress and now they get to
express it I was talking to a cab driver
a couple weeks ago who was an immigrant
and he said that he just doesn't
understand how the country could think
that a woman is up to the task of being
the president despite the fact that
there are these dozens of countries as
you can point to where women have had
presidencies and you know the countries
still exist they didn't kind of collapse
and go out of existence and so these are
dynamics I think are very real and in a
way that we had not anticipated and wait
I don't think we even thought was
possible the current presidential cycle
has brought those to the surface and I
don't think that is also i don't think
that this ends should he would hillary
clinton be elected these dynamics will
be present and they may be more
vitriolic and they may feel more
entitled and more victimized and i think
there has something to do with the way
in which we've taught men to understand
themselves in the society and i also
think in some ways if you can kind of
take the silver lining approach to this
in somebody's is better that you have
this wound being lanced right now so all
of it has come up the disbelief around
issues of sexual assault has now become
part of the presidential election is not
simply a question that people ask during
a debate or someone can give a canned
answer we are actually processing this
like we are actually figuring out what
it looks like when someone says that
I've been sexually assaulted and people
don't believe them because that person
is a woman and that is happening now and
I think that it's also we are looking at
the the biases that people have in the
presidential debates where Clinton would
say something and her opponent would
speak over her and and dismiss our
perspectives and all these things has
become an object lesson in it in a way
that I think might not have happened
these things would still have been
present but they've been submerged but
now it's all come to the surface and all
the messiness is there and we had no
choice but to confront it there's a lot
that we could talk about with this
election but one of them one notable
things and offices i think that the
overt fascistic overtones of what has
happened over the past year and you know
american society american politics are
notable we typically think of societies
have suffered some great trauma when
national humiliation is being
susceptible to the appeals of fascism
kind of hyper nationalism the
authoritarian figure who says i will
protect you you know these appeals to
order and what people perceive to have
been a disordered society and we think
that when people have experienced a
national trauma that they're more
susceptible to this except in the united
states this is not coming on the heels
of losing a war or having been
humiliated in the kind of court of
public opinion internationally this turn
toward a movement that has these
overtones of fascism has come on the
heels of the first black president see
which is has been largely successful and
so we're looking at people who feel that
the prospect of African Americans no
longer being in the subordinate position
is as traumatizing to them as other
societies that have lost wars have been
embarrassed in these other kinds of ways
and felt the need to reassert their
masculinity and in movements that were
fascist and so that's very disturbing to
me and we've also seen a kind of return
to McCarthyism of a certain variety
we're the things that he did was game
the media in particular ways so he would
know that under the kind of idea of
objective journalism if he said
something that was untrue newspapers
were going to report it they might
report a opposing opinion but they
weren't going to come down on the side
and say but one of these is more true
than the other it is the one side says
the earth is round one side says the
earth is flat and this is where we
the story and so by doing this he could
get lots of misinformation out into the
public that was self-serving he also did
this as a means of ginning up the level
of fear in society which worked well
demagogues kind of bread and butter is
is working on the fears of population
and so even when newspapers would fact
check McCarthy by the time they kind of
dispelled one lie he had told three more
and by the time they get to those three
was now up to nine or ten others there
was this exponential kind of mendacity
and we've seen that dynamic in this
election as well even with people in the
press you know some in some instances
saying that they did not believe that it
was their job to fact-check a
presidential candidate chris wallace fox
news made that point about the the
presidential debates and even then
implicit in McCarthy's time there was a
kind of conflict of interest the media
had because while McCarthy was a
demagogue and a disreputable person he
was also a person who sold newspapers if
you put him on the cover of your
newspaper on the front page people were
going to pick it up and buy it and read
it the same dynamic happens now
especially in cable media in 2016 where
the implicit conflict of interests
involves a person who's saying things
that are absolutely untrue but whose
name Garner's ratings and so which in
turn generate revenue and so these are
the dynamics that we've seen you know
sixty years after McCarthy we still are
not any more adept at dealing with the
dynamics that allowed the coffee to rise
I think that's something that should
give all of us pause there's something
which we all be concerned about